so much news so many things to be
excited about so many things to be
depress about so here's the deal
Mike Flynn just pled guilty to a charge
of lying to the FBI we'll explain what
that means the Republicans are going to
pass a tax cut today we'll explain what
that means and Kate Stanley's killer was
just let go on charges of murder he will
still go to jail on gun charges we'll
explain what that means so lots of
explaining to plus the mailbag so many
things I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
some days are like drinking from a
firehose and this is that day there are
just too many big news stories happening
all at once and I'm sure that by the end
of the show another big news story will
have broken destroying the rest of the
structure of the show but before we get
to any of the big news and it is really
big news today first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Birch gold
if all of this makes you feel just a
little unsettled if all this makes you
feel like perhaps you want some solidity
in your life you should have some of
your money in precious metals everyone's
portfolio at least part of it should be
in precious metals the people to go to
for that are the folks over at Birch
gold thanks to a little-known IRS tax
law you can even move your IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver which is
perfect for people who want to ensure
that their hard-earned retirement
savings are protected from either
inflation or any stock market crashes
that may be to come they've a
long-standing track record over a Burch
gold of continued success thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact our friends over
at Birch gold group right now to request
a free 16 page information kit on
physical precious metals to get that kit
go over to wwm slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben that lets them
know that we sent you and make sure you
ask all your questions make sure they
get all your answers and then when
you're ready to invest in precious
metals Birch gold those are the people
to talk to about it
birchgold.com slash button so ok here we
go
so the breaking news from this morning
just before the show is that the FBI has
basically now made clear that Mike Flynn
lied to them so Mike Flynn just pled
guilty to a charge of lying to the FBI
what did he lie to the FBI about
apparently he lied to the FBI because he
had been speaking with the Russian
ambassador surrogate kiss lyac in order
to convince kiss lyac to lay off of
backlash against the united states after
the Obama administration is - in its
waning days as retaliation for supposed
Russian election interference put new
sanctions on the Russians and you recall
that Putin didn't respond to that and
there's speculation that was because
Flynn had reached out to Putin and told
him don't do it things are gonna change
come January 20th I said at the time I
don't see what is particularly wrong
with that he was a transition official
it was already pretty clear who's gonna
be part of the administration there's no
real violation of law there so what's
the big deal the fact though that he was
allowed to plead on only the charge with
regard to lying to the FBI suggests to
me that
he is about to flip on the Trump
administration and that suspicion has
now been confirmed the reason I say that
this is pretty clearly a plea deal that
minimizes what Flynn did is because
there have been reports coming out of
the Mueller probe that they were
investigating Flynn for having made a
deal with the Turkish government to
kidnap a guy who's a Turkish to senator
from the United States and send him back
to Turkey they didn't paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars by the Turkish
government in other words it looks like
there were more serious charges on the
table and in exchange for those charges
going away Flynn took this much lesser
charge in order to get this thing over
with so according to ABC News here's
what they are saying they are now saying
that Flynn had resisted flipping on
other members of the administration for
months given his close ties with the
Trump administration but he apparently
felt abandoned by the administration in
recent weeks thanks to mounting legal
debts and plans to sell his house to
help defray cost according to ABC News
this is one of the big problems
seriously one of the big problems with
the with special counsel investigations
everyone is forced to lawyer up
lawyers are incredibly expensive if you
are just a normal person you can't
afford the lawyer and up that cost to
fight people like Robert Mueller and
there was no one there to pick up the
cost for Mike Flynn so in order to
defray those costs he's apparently
cutting a deal with the with the Mueller
investigation Brian Ross on ABC News
special report is reporting that flem
has promised quote full cooperation to
the Mueller team and is prepared to
testify that as a candidate Donald Trump
quote directed him to make contact with
the Russians now this the people are
left are going nuts clear that we're
almost there almost there again this
means that Mike Flynn is going to
testify that Donald Trump told him to
coordinate campaign activities with the
Russians and that's why there that's why
Hillary Clinton lost the election that
is not clear by any stretch of the
imagination there is lots of
coordination between the Hillary Clinton
team for example and we know members of
the Ukrainian government the idea that
members of campaigns don't talk to
foreign officials is just not true so
it's quite possible that Trump told
Flint I want you to go talk to Putin
talk to him about what their priorities
are what our priorities are if I become
president of the United States none of
that is illegal none of that is illegal
the only thing that would be illegal is
presumably if there is actually
conspiracy an exchange of information
that would be designed to subvert the
United States election and there are
actual conspiracy laws and you'd have to
see if they violate them legally and
that
that's a little bit difficult to prove
collusion is not a crime in other words
even if collusion occurred that might be
grounds for the political crime of
impeachment that would require
impeachment but it's not grounds for any
actual crime that has been committed
collusion is not a crime there is no
statute on collusion
it's a vague term of art so this does
not get all the way toward proving
anything about Trump we still have to
see what Flynn has to say now there are
two possibilities here one is that Flynn
is actually gonna say some stuff that's
really damaging about the president in
favor of this possibility is the is the
reality that Mueller cut a deal with
Flynn and that basically let Flynn
almost entirely off the hook for all of
these other charges so why would you cut
such a deal that was generous to Flynn
because Flynn's about to give you a
bunch of good stuff right think of your
Godfather
right Frank Pentangeli he's gonna get
off the hook so long as he testifies
against Michael Corleone okay the reason
that you're going to downgrade charges
is because you're trying to get Flynn to
actually give you valuable information
if you don't believe Flynn has valuable
information you don't cut a deal with
him at all you just send him to jail
so that's cutting in favor of that
there's also the possibility however
that the special counsel is charging
Flynn on the line to the FBI charge
because what he's hoping is that now
he's going to be able to go after other
members of the Trump administration for
the same thing but there'll be a sort of
domino effect that he's sort of fishing
but what he's doing here is he's gonna
nail Flynn on the line to the FBI charge
got him to plead out on that and then he
they're gonna go back and talk to some
other folks who've talked to the FBI I
think in the administration that
includes I think Kushner's talked to the
FBI I think there's several other
members of the administration who talked
to the FBI the possibility exists that
they will try to have Flynn testify
against those people and then try and
get those people on charges of lying to
the FBI and try and flip this upward
right create a domino effect and maybe
one of those people flips on the
president and finally spills the beans
about the president but that is not the
same thing as Flynn himself is directly
going to implicate the president and any
sort of criminal activity so it's a
little early for all of the speculation
that's going on it is not clear by any
stretch of the imagination that all of
this is that all of this is is going to
bring down the President of the United
States there is a lot of there's a lot
of I think unbasic ulation from both
sides people on the right going there's
a big nothing right they didn't charge
them with anything and people on the
left going they've charged him with
something we're about to get Trump
president Pence is coming I don't know
that any of this is is gonna be true so
we just don't know
yet we do know that something more is
happening the investigation than we
thought was happening yesterday
Reuters by the way ABC is saying that
candidate Trump ordered him to make
contact with the Russians that's what
ABC is reporting Reuters is reporting
that Flynn is saying the transition team
ordered him to make contact with the
Russians if it's the transition team
that has nothing to do at the campaign
so it's hard even to imagine what the
crime would be at that point the
transition team ordering Flynn to talk
with the Russians like who cares unless
we're just gonna round up a bunch of
people unjustly and this is something
that special councils have done in the
past you recall that it was Special
Counsel I believe is Patrick Fitzgerald
who went after scooter libby scooter
libby was working for the President of
the United States he's an American
lawyer from a performer advisor to VP
Dick Cheney and you recall that he
actually ended up in jail and he was
pardoned by President and Trent works
his sentence was commuted more
specifically by President Bush because
scooter libby had apparently Phibbs it
to the FBI but there was no underlying
crime so they got Scooter Libby for
fibbing to the FBI but they are
obstruction of justice but he had not
actually done anything wrong there was
no underlying crime nothing criminal had
taken place he hadn't done it nobody in
the administration had done it basically
remember that about Valerie Plame the
situation in that particular case was
the Valerie Plame was in under it was a
covert CIA agent she was in Washington
she was not really like in the field and
there was a leak about her identity
after Joe Wilson her husband suggested
that the Bush administration had lied
about yellowcake from Niger being sold
to the Iraqi regime and the person who
actually ended up doing it I believe was
Richard Armitage that that was the the
person would end up leaking it was was
not in fact Scooter Libby it was Richard
Armitage a Libby had apparently fibbed
to the FBI in the process of the
investigation and they decided to go
after Libya instead it was really a
bunch of nonsense they went after him
just because they felt like going after
him and that's why President Bush ended
up commuting his sentence he really
should have pardoned him in this
particular case it could be something
very similar we just don't know at this
point so anybody who's telling you it's
all over we know what the story is Trump
is going down don't believe them at this
point there's just not enough
information on that yet for that to be
the case we don't know what Mike Lynn is
going to tell the the FBI what he has
told the FBI at this point so we're
gonna find out we're gonna find out by
the way it is worth noting also
the White House says that they have no
comments on this at this point which is
the proper stance in the middle of legal
proceeding the last thing you want to do
is start going out and mouthing off Mike
Flynn had made comments in 2016 it's
gonna get played all over the news today
that if he did a tenth of what Hillary
Clinton had done he would be in jail
today you know there's a real
possibility that that is that that is
true by the way that he really did not
do much here and that he could end up in
jail anyway just because this is the way
the political prosecutions go we're
saying that because if I a guy who knows
this business if I did 1/10 1/10 of what
she did I would be in jail today so
crooked Hillary Clinton leave this race
now so I'm not saying it's a political
prosecution I don't know you don't know
nobody knows so don't buy all the
speculation that's going on today it's
time to hold judgment and abeyance then
say actually have more information okay
so that is big story number one big
story number two is that Kate Steinle
skilar was acquitted yesterday on
charges of murder the the facts of the
case I want to give you the entire facts
of the case that you know what the jury
may or may not have been doing so let's
begin with what exactly happened Sarah
rump has a very good piece over a red
state talking about what exactly
happened in this case so you recall that
during the campaign the Kate Stanley
case came up over and over beautiful
young woman who was killed on a San
Francisco pier by an illegal immigrant
the illegal immigrants had a gun that
had been stolen from a federal agents
car I guess and the gun had been fired
the the guy admitted to killing the girl
the only question was did he do it was
it an accident or did he do it on
purpose or was a criminal negligence so
he was charged with second-degree murder
the jury also could have found for
involuntary manslaughter that was on the
table as well it seems to me that
second-degree murder was too high a
charge and that involuntary manslaughter
seems like the the situation that best
fits the evidence this may be a case to
give the best gloss on the jury this may
be a case where the jury was basically
thrown off by the prosecutors failing to
press the charges properly that's that's
a possibility here and I'll explain why
in just a second so here is what is
undisputed on July 1st 2015 Kate Steinle
was fatally struck in the back by a
single bullet as she walked on pier 14
with
Father to view the San Francisco Bay hos
ENS Garcia's aarathi was a Mexican
citizen illegally in the United States
and he fired the gun that they killed
Stanley so first of all for political
reasons it doesn't matter what the guy
was convicted or not this guy should not
have been in the United States he had
been deported I believe six times but
five times before for seven separate
crimes if the man had been a citizen in
the state of California he probably
would have already been in jail for life
because there's a three strikes law in
the state of California mostly it
involves violent crime not drug offenses
but the idea that he would have been out
on the street is absurd he would not
have been out on the street if he'd been
convicted of a bunch of different felony
drug offenses he would be in jail right
now he would not be out on the street if
you were citizen so he actually had the
special privilege of being deported then
recrossing the border coming back and
then you recall he was picked up on a
drug charge by the local authorities the
feds found out about they asked the
local authorities to hold him so they
could come get him and because San
Francisco is a sanctuary city he was
then released into the general
population as well where he got ahold of
this gun and killed Kate Steinle now was
this a murder or was this an involuntary
manslaughter I think he's an open
question it's pretty clear to me that
this was an involuntary manslaughter
I'll explain to you why in just a second
I'll give you all the legal breakdown
putting on my lawyer hat but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the US ECA so according to the
US Department of Justice over 34,000
carjackings happen every single year do
you know how to protect yourself and
your family do you know when it's
actually legal to draw a gun well the
self defense experts at the US ECA
created a free video series to show you
exactly what to do during a deadly
carjacking but it's only free for a
limited time don't be a victim it's
great it gives you all the information
that you need go to defend my family now
calm for a hundred percent free instant
access let's defend my family now calm
for a hundred percent free instant
access the training videos show you how
to use cover how to get your gun on
target how to turn the tables on any
attacker in under two seconds you'll
need more than basic skills that you've
learned at the range if you actually
want to be able to defend yourself
that's why you need to go over to my
friends at USC seeing at the training
you need take advantage of the free
training it's free but only for now so
go to defend my family now calm for 100%
free access 100% free access to fend my
family now calm descends really soon so
do it now defend my family now dot-com
all right so here is the here is the
case for the defense so basically what
happened is that this piece of garbage
illegal immigrant and he's
in a piece of garbage because he's an
illegal immigrant he's a piece of
garbage who is an illegal immigrant he
was walking around on the pier and he
has the gun the defense says that he
found the gun on the pier okay this is
like the lamest excuse ever how many
times you been walking around just find
a gun lying around usually you're
walking around and boom look there's a
gun okay this it never happens and the
idea that this happens in San Francisco
on a regular basis is insane San
Francisco has some of the tightest gun
laws in the nation so he says that he's
walking around he finds a gun he picks
it up because he picks it up and then
magically the gun just goes off it is
clear from the evidence that the bullet
hit the cement before it hit Steinle so
it wasn't like he picked up the gun
aimed it Stanley shot her in the back
okay he he picked up the gun he fired it
it bounced off the concrete it hit Kate
Steinle in the back he killed her
and the the defense was that he
basically that he's a that
basically was walking around gone he
picks it up it goes boom in his hand for
no reason at all it's just a pure
accident the bullet bounces Skip's off
to concrete and hits Kate Steinle in the
back and she dies the problem with this
particular theory is several-fold one
the gun had been missing for four days
from a federal agents car somehow it
just winds up in the hands with the SI
legal immigrant criminal repeat criminal
it is magic it was like a normal person
who found it on the boardwalk over at
the San Francisco pier wasn't me it
wasn't you it was an illegal immigrant
who's been deported five times he's just
magically amazing how that works he
picks it up they they question him and
in during the questioning he says that
he was trying to fire it at the seals
they saw I see it that he saw a seal out
there or a seal I and he's trying to
fire it at sea lion and then his story
changed and he said that he had that it
fired by accident
according to according the San Francisco
Chronicle defense lawyer said the
shooting was an accident that happened
when Garcia Zarate but a history of drug
crimes with no record of violence found
the gun wrapped in a t-shirt or cloth
under his seat on the pier just seconds
before it discharged in his hands
because that's what I do when I see like
a bundle of cloth under my seat at a
public pier I reached down they start
investigating and if I find a gun I go
arou Gooden
okay Matt Gonzalez if the public
defender's office said his client had
never handled a gun yes I'm sure and was
scared by the noise prompting him to
fling the weapon into the bay okay so
number one if you accidentally fire a
gun so apparently he says he was scared
by the noise it wasn't that it wasn't
that he shot the woman and then thought
that he would be convicted of it and so
he threw the evidence
into the bay instead he took the gun and
he threw it in the bay because he was
scared by the noise that's what I do
when my child scares me my child makes a
really loud noise and we're by the ocean
I just take my kid and fling him in the
ocean let me just tell you this is this
is something that normal people do on a
regular basis oh my god a car backfired
let's drive it into the ocean that's it
that's something that you're scared of
the fire oh my god a gun made noise what
is this boom boom stick okay during the
trial jurors watched video from Garcia
sera tease for our police interrogation
in which you offer varying statements
about his actions on the pier number 1
when someone constantly changes their
story that's a pretty good indicator
they're not telling the truth okay at
one point he said he had aimed at a sea
animal at another point he said the gun
had been under a rag that lay on the
ground into the waterfront and that it
fired when he stepped on it
and Zala said it was clear in the video
by the way guns don't fire when you step
on them just note to everybody yeah
there are people who are saying that was
a Sig Sauer and this is a Sig Sauer with
with a a quick trigger because it was
basically set up for a federal agent who
knows how to use it really had four
pounds of trigger pressure okay even if
it only has four pounds of trigger
pressure you can't step on a gun into
fires okay as a typical rule that is
it's extraordinarily rare like something
has to actually push on the trigger in
order to make the gun fire that's not
how guns fire almost the unless that the
the hammer was already cocked or
something and Zala said it was clear in
the video that he had not that he did
not fully understand what the officers
were asking through an officer Spanish
translation well that's sort of his
problem I mean they're speaking Spanish
them it's not like they're speaking
English and he doesn't understand grainy
footage surveillance footage taken by
the camera position a quarter-mile away
showed that just before Garcia's harathi
took a seat on the pier a group of six
people gathered at the spot
Gonzales it was possible those people
had discarded the gun that killed
Steinle yes I'm sure that's what
happened six people just gathered and
decided that instead of throwing the gun
in the bay to discard the gun which is
five feet away they decided what would
be better I we need to get rid of this
gun you know we'll just leave it lying
around best idea I've ever had we're not
gonna take this gun toss it in the bank
no we're gonna leave it right here
for some poor unsuspecting illegal
immigrant to find and randomly shoot a
lady okay so Stanley was not hit
directly but rather the bullet hit the
concrete ground and ricocheted up to hit
her the gun was a Sig Sauer been stolen
four days prior the defense also
presented evidence that the Sig Sauer
has a propensity to accidentally fire so
it has a hair-trigger in single action
mode apparently among well-trained users
it has a lengthy history of accidental
discharges
okay accidental discharges does not mean
that you have not acted with criminal
negligence if you pick up a gun and you
point it anywhere near the vicinity of
people and your hand is anywhere near
the trigger that does not count as a
pure accident okay a gun is a dangerous
weapon everyone knows this okay this is
why you are taught when you buy a gun
when you train with the gun you are
trying never point the gun anywhere you
are not willing to kill somebody never
point the gun anywhere you're not
willing to destroy never have your
finger anywhere near the trigger if you
don't mean to fire it okay but the idea
is that again this guy's dunt and he
walks up and he doesn't know what a gun
is it just looks like a fancy a fancy
cheese cutter and he picks it up and
then boom it goes off in his hand
because he never even touched the
trigger okay this is so they say that
this is the defense presenting a
reasonable doubt case and they said he's
a homeless illegal immigrant unfamiliar
with the gun and that's why okay so I
think that what happened here if you're
trying to make the best case for the
jury is that there is a prosecutorial
overreach so they pushed hard for a
first-degree murder verdict or a
second-degree murder verdict which would
suggest that you must have intent right
that you have to have intent to have
killed involuntary manslaughter does not
require intent so the the prosecution in
this case said that he was playing like
a game of Russian Roulette in his head
and just shot the lady that's weak what
they should have charged was involuntary
manslaughter they overcharged which a
lot of prosecutors do they overcharged
what they should have done is charged
and voluntary manslaughter second-degree
murder in the in California is willful
foot but not deliberate like for example
you fire a gun into a crowded room you
don't mean to kill any specific person
but you know there's a good possibility
somebody is going to die
willful but not deliberately involuntary
manslaughter in California the standard
is without malice without intent to kill
with reckless disregard for human life
so the difference between involuntary
manslaughter and excusable accident is
participation in either unlawful acts
not amounting to a felony to that be
picking up an illegal gun or a lawful
act involving a high degree of risk of
death or great bodily injury that would
involve picking up a gun and points get
it anywhere in the vicinity of people
and in fact there's a law firm out here
in California that has a defense law
firm that has very good rundown on this
law and the exact example they use been
voluntary manslaughter is a woman who's
in a fight with her husband brandishing
a gun at her husband the gun
accidentally goes off and kills her
husband right that falls under it
involuntary manslaughter
okay Jeff Sessions has a statement on
this was clearly involuntary
manslaughter the jury could have found
that it's possible they decided
throw out everything because the
prosecutor didn't do their job but
whatever it is this is an unjust verdict
the guy should be in prison for a very
long time for at least involuntary
manslaughter and beyond that the reason
this is a political issue is because
this bastard never should have been in
the United States in the first place he
should not have been here now President
Trump when he says we need a wall the
reason we need a wall is because it's
not enough to just repeatedly to poor
people you actually have to have some
way of preventing them from recrossing
into the country because you have
sanctuary cities you have places where
these people can hide you know Trump
should be making hay while the Sun
shines out of this because he is right
this is why Trump won it's because it's
issues like the Kate Steinle issue as I
said last night on Fox News Jeff
Sessions issued the Attorney General
issued a statement the feds may bring
charges of their own Jeff Sessions said
when jurisdictions choose to return
criminal aliens to the streets rather
than turning them over to federal
immigration authorities they put the
public safety at risk
san Francisco's decision to protect
criminal aliens led to the preventable
and heartbreaking death of Kate Steinle
while the state of California sought a
murder charge for the man who caused
Miss Stanley's death a man who had not
have been on the streets of San
Francisco if the city simply honored an
ice detainer the people ultimately
convicted him a felon in possession of a
firearm so again once you're a felon in
possession of a firearm if that firearm
goes off and you kill somebody it's
pretty hard to see charging and
convicting someone of felony possession
of a firearm without also charging them
with and convicting them of involuntary
manslaughter in a case like this the
Department of Justice will continue to
ensure that all jurisdictions place the
safety and security of their communities
above the convenience of criminal aliens
there should be blowback on sanctuary
cities and it shouldn't have to do
anything with it with the verdict here
if the guy was convicted there should
still be blowback on sanctuary cities so
that's that's worth while noting as well
okay so that is big piece of news number
two okay big piece of news number three
the Mitch McConnell is now saying that
the Republicans have the votes in the
Senate for this tax cut so again I'll
give you the latest on that in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at policy genius so if
you don't have life insurance you
certainly should especially if you have
kids if you have loved ones if you die
and they're not taken care of you're
gonna beat yourself up or you what if
you weren't dead but it's not a great
idea to not have life insurance I have
life insurance
it is totally worthwhile especially
again if you leaving loved ones behind
you want to make sure that you're
insured it's not everybody treats this
is like it's a taboo topic to talk about
life insurance I don't think it's taboo
at all I think it's necessary I'm not
saying you're going to die I'm saying
being
in case you do I mean that's the same
thing as saying he should have health
insurance or car insurance and the
purpose of insurance is to prevent
greater loss and than just your death
hey that's that's the whole point of it
well most people just sort of go to the
family firm around the corner that's not
gonna get you the best price what you
want is policy genius policy genius lets
you compare life insurance from the top
providers online it takes as little as
five minutes if you're busy one minute
per day for five days if you find a
policy you like and you want to know
more you can talk to one of their
licensed experts but if you're just
browsing and you don't have to talk to
anybody just browse they don't just do
life insurance by the way they do
disability insurance renter's insurance
pet insurance I don't know what pet
insurance is that if you're if your pet
gets sick it's probably pet health
insurance I don't have a pet so I
wouldn't know in any case but if you
need life insurance try policy genius
compare life insurance online on your
own terms
policy genius.com again that's policy
genius.com you should only be forced to
speak to an agent's if you really want
to and policy genius will let you avoid
speaking to insurance agents which is a
wonderful thing in and of itself policy
genius.com make sure that your family is
taken care of okay so mr. McConnell has
now announced on the floor of the Senate
that we are about to pass this tax
reform bill the tax reform bill it has
at least fifty votes maybe fifty-one it
depends on on what bob Corker decides
maybe they get fifty two but bottom line
is that it is a good shot that this is
that it is a good shot that that the tax
bill wins it is unclear what exactly is
in this thing now because they were
fussing around with it
as late as yesterday right now as of
last night the Republicans were
redrawing the tax bill to reduce the
size of the tax cuts because there is
report yesterday that the deficits were
too high there are a lot of people today
talking about deficits deficits all the
tax cuts gonna create deficit I am
deeply concerned about deficits but
let's be clear about something
it does not create deficits for me to
keep more of my own money
it creates deficits for you to spend
money I did not give you okay if you
this is I hate this logic that it's
constantly used by the left that if you
if I'm paying 50 percent taxes and
you're taking in a million dollars from
me right which is not accurate but let's
say I were paying 50 percent tax and
you're taking a million dollars from me
then and you were spending two million
dollars so we have a million dollar
deficit well if you reduce my taxes by
percents and I'm only paying 500,000
then you've increased the deficit by
$500,000 nonsense you should spend less
ok these are two separate line items in
your house
the idea that you spending less money
creates a deficit that you taking less
of my money creates a deficit that's
just foolishness okay it's not a matter
of you allowing me to keep more of my
own money it's a matter of your spending
too much money with a great driver of
the debt in the United States is not in
fact tax cuts it is not Wars the great
driver is what constitutes 60% of the
American federal budget that is Social
Security Medicare Medicaid welfare
programs that is at least two-thirds of
the American budget okay the idea that
it's all these other things it's just
not true
and so I hate these rules one thing that
I would say to the Republicans listen
I'm really glad they're gonna get these
tax cuts I think that it is worthwhile I
would vote for the tax cuts even though
I'm a deficit Hawk because I want them
to cut crap on the other side yeah I've
never understood this argument that a
lot of people on the right make that
recovery meant revenue will go up if we
cut taxes I don't care whether
government revenue goes up I don't care
I don't want the government revenue to
go up I want them to have less money I
want the government not to spend as many
of my dollars hey this is the sort of
downside to the Laffer curve so the
Laffer curve is true the Laffer curve
for those who know know I've explained
it on the program before art Laffer
famously had what he called the Laffer
curve the Laffer curve basically looks
like this I will draw you the Laffer
curve the Laffer curve says that if you
have a tax rate here on this axis on the
y axis and here is 100 and here is zero
and then here you have government revit
garment receipts government receipts
right then and here again you have zero
and here you have 100 then what will
happen is that as the tax rate goes up
you will see the government receipts go
up but there is a there's a law of
diminishing returns right and so the
curve that looks like this all right the
curve looks like that that if you if you
tax at zero the government receipts will
be zero if you tax it a hundred the
government receipts will be zero the
reason for that is because if you tax it
a hundred no one is gonna bother making
any money they're not gonna sit home
they're gonna say why would I work for
the government you're not paying me all
right so that's what the Laffer curve
says what the Laffer curve also says is
that there is a point let's say that you
are here on the Laffer curve let's say
the tax rate is where this X is
than what you would be better off doing
to increase government receipts is to
actually lower the tax rate right you
would actually be better off lowering
the tax rate that would be the idea now
when you lower the tax rate that you
would actually end up increasing the
government receipts I actually mixed up
the axes here this should be the
government it recedes in this should be
the tax rate so that's the so the idea
there is that if you want to increase
government receipts lower the tax rate
if the taxes are too high I don't care I
don't care people say well you know the
who says the tax rates too high maybe
we're perfect right now maybe it ought
to be higher what if I don't care about
the government receipts what if I think
the government receipts should go downs
that they spend less money on stupid
crap how about that in any case the
leading GOP senators are saying the
Republicans redrew the tax bill last
night to reduce the size of the tax cuts
John Cornyn said the move came after the
Senate parliamentarian ruled against a
complex trigger mechanism that would
have automatically cut back the taxes if
they didn't produce economic growth and
higher than expected tax revenue so what
the Republicans were trying to do is
they're trying to cut taxes in a in a
significant way and then they would have
a trigger in the bill that said if the
government revenues do not increase by a
certain amount then we will ratchet back
down the tax in the tax cuts that seems
to me a silly idea again because I think
that the entire the entire the entirety
of this particular regulation is solely
that we have to we have to be
deficit-neutral in order to pass
anything it's just a recipe to game the
numbers that's all the Senate
parlamentary er doesn't sentiment Senate
parliamentarian doesn't know better than
you do how much revenue the government's
going to take in the Senate
parliamentarian has you know would have
ruled that Obamacare was deficit neutral
which it clearly is not so I don't buy
any of this - but this is good news for
the Trump administration they do need a
big win in terms of policy the tax cuts
are a big win in terms of policy while
they're unpopular now nobody likes
having less money in their pocket and
while Democrats are busy complaining
about how this is a bad bill very few
people are going to consider it a bad
bill with the stock market continues to
go up and if they get more back in their
tax refunds so it's it's a big win for
the Trump administration for certain
okay so before I go any further here
there's there's some other news that I
want to talk about the possibility of a
government shutdown
the battle between Jimmy Kimmel and Roy
Moore and we gotta get to the mailbag so
we're gonna go about an hour and a half
today on today's show we're gonna get to
all of those things but for that you
have to subscribe to
the daily wire so $9.99 gets you
subscription to daily wire you get my
show live you get the Andrew Clavin show
live you get the michael moles show
lobby it's part of the mailbag in just a
few minutes you see this these are my
written questions for the mailbag but
you can ask questions live to me now
today if you subscribe right now so if
you're watching right now on Facebook or
YouTube go over right now subscribe then
you can ask questions and coming up with
our fourth episode of the conversation
coming up on Tuesday December 12th at 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific featuring
your favorite voice parentheses me
subscribe today to be a part of the
conversation and ask me questions which
I will either answer or mocking then
answer in the order they are entered
into the live feed if they are good and
they're not all about putting my
conversation will stream live on The
Daily wire Facebook page and the daily Y
our YouTube channel it'll be free for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask questions to ask questions as a
subscriber make sure you log into our
website daily wire and then head over to
the conversation page to watch the live
stream and after that you just start
typing into the daily wired chat books
where I'm going to answer questions as
they come in for an entire hour Alicia
will be going through it and finding the
questions that are good once again if
you're a subscriber you can get your
questions answered by me December 12th 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation this also works if you're
an annual subscriber that's $99 a year
and for that price a cheaper price than
the monthly you also get this the very
finest and beverage vessels reminding
you each and every day that your
constituents of the ben shapiro show and
daily wire the leftist here's hot or
cold tumbler often imitated never
duplicated so go and check that out or
subscribe later to our channel over at
YouTube SoundCloud iTunes leave us a
review we always appreciate again
largest and fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
all righty so here we are and it looks
like a government shutdown may be in the
works and this is a good government
shutdown for President Trump I said
yesterday I think the president Trump
would win on a government shutdown issue
with the Democrats particularly after
Steinle he should be pushing for funding
in the in the new government shutdown
negotiations he should basically be
saying I want funding for the wall in
this bill and if you don't give it to me
then I'm just not gonna sign the funding
bill I'm not gonna increase the debt
ceiling I'm not gonna sign funding and
there'll be a shutdown because you guys
are willing to obstruct so that we don't
have any sort of physical barrier that
prevent people from entering the country
as in this Kate Steinle case Trump has
the upper hand he has the bully pulpit
he should be willing to use it he should
at least get some concessions from
Democrats if he does not I will count
that as a loss for the administration
Trump says the shutdown could be good
for him I don't think that that's wrong
I don't think that that's wrong I mean I
think that everybody in the
administration should stop leaking like
my god folks like just stop it
but but Trump is not wrong when he says
the government shutdown sometimes
benefits the president that was the
logic that is used for Obama when when
Cruz was involved in a government
shutdown okay so that's what's going on
with the government shutdown we'll bring
you more on that if it actually
materializes meanwhile the battle
continues over Roy Moore in Alabama and
just want to show you the reactionary
nature of American politics so as I have
said to you I believe that Roy Moore did
the things he's alleged to have done I
think that because there's been no any
where near a convincing rebuttal of any
of the testimony or evidence put forward
by the accusers meanwhile Hollywood is
basically willing to ignore a lot of the
the evils in their own midst and of
course they are very upset about Roy
Moore because Roy Moore is a Republican
they were all defending Bill Clinton and
they would again today if they had the
choice as far as I know Jimmy Kimmel has
not been commenting on Al Franken maybe
he has if he has then I miss it and I
apologize but I haven't seen that Jimmy
Kimmel deployed a guy down to Roy
Moore's row a church in Alabama and and
this guy went into a speech the Roy
Moore was giving it the church and
started berating him at the church in
the middle of his speech he was then
removed so this is Jimmy Kimmel's guy
I'm not I can't remember the name of
this fellow excitement watch Jimmy's
show but the I believe that his name was
let's see rich Barbieri who's better
known as Jake
so here's here's a a pretend Roy Moore
superfan who's actually an employee of
Jimmy Kimmel's okay so he's removed and
then Roy Moore tweets out at Jimmy
Kimmel they getting a big tweet fight
right and there's a fight that only
helps where a more and only helps Jimmy
Kimmel and doesn't help anybody who's
rational on these subjects and trying to
figure out exactly how to vote or who's
guilty or who is innocent so the tweet
fight goes something like this so we
have the tweets so here are the tweets
so Roy Moore tweets out if you want to
mock our Christian values come down here
to Alabama into a man-to-man and then
Jimmy Kimmel of course jumps right on
this and Jimmy Kimmel is better at this
then Roy Moore and so he tweets out
sounds great Roy let me know when he had
some Christian values and I'll be there
and not unfair considering the man's
been charged of has been you know
accused of sexual molestation of
underaged women and then Roy Moore fires
back and he fires he says despite DC and
Hollywood elites bigotry toward
southerners Jimmy we will save you a
seat on the front pew okay so he's just
going in for more and then Jimmy Kimmel
responds okay Roy but I'm leaving my
daughter's at home yes what are that
cute little leather vest okay so the
only people who are benefited by this
sort of by this sort of stuff are Jimmy
Kimmel who looks like he gets to virtue
signal to his audience and Roy Moore who
gets to look like he's virtually
signalling to his audience because
Hollywood is so bad and Hollywood is so
terrible and all this nonsense the
reality is that everybody has already
made up their mind on Roy Moore all of
the virtue signaling on the back of this
seems to me a little bit much I think
that there is a complex moral calculus
that is happening for people who are in
Alabama it's it's a very similar moral
calculus to the one that was made during
the 2016 election I think some people of
good heart are gonna come down on one
side some people of good heart are gonna
come
on the other side I think that it is not
the right moral decision to vote for Roy
Moore in Alabama the man is a credibly
alleged child molester but on the other
hand I think that to do the kind of
virtue signaling that Jimmy Kimmel is
doing and that Roy Moore is doing off
the back of Hollywood all this does is
exacerbate the the reactionary politics
the the reactionary political moment
that we're already in okay so I want to
do some things I like and then some
things I hate so let's do some things I
like all righty so the things that I
like today I don't know the the street
artists there's a street artist who has
struck again and this is pretty
spectacular so Sabo has now unleashed a
politically charged installation making
fun of Al Franken here is what he did so
there's this awful this movie that looks
just awful that's coming out the
greatest showman on earth is out it's
called about PT Barnum with Hugh Jackman
that basically looks like LGBT rights in
1905 it's like there's a bearded woman
be yourself that's what the circus is
about no the circus was about is showing
people who were perceived to be freaks
by the people of the time and then
charging money for that so no not really
so much
no but it's about enlightenment and in
case I'll save my critique of what I
think will be a garbage movie for an
actual deconstruction of the culture but
what is hilarious is that I don't know
they even did this they apparently
apparently basically repelled up to this
billboard I think this in LA and they
took a giant photo of Al Franken from
the Leon Sweden photo where he's trying
to grope her breasts while she's
sleeping and it has Al Franken popping
in from the side of the billboard to try
and grope who's the zendaya the trying
to trying to grope this woman from
behind just spectacular work by Sabo I
love it he's holding us over at the
Daily wire when I heard Franken rehash
Bill Clinton's I have to get back to
work for the American people speech I
knew I had to take a punch at gropey al
why is it the left never steps down but
always insists when Republicans are
caught instant in scandals they do just
that the hypocrisy is staggering
I hope these latest accusations cause
him to step down just spectacular it's
right off the 405 freeway near National
Boulevard which is a couple of miles
away from the Fox Studios and he said
that he was he made the alteration
temporary because he didn't really want
to be prosecuted so
it's easily removed but it's pretty damn
funny that's pretty spectacular stuff so
well done Sabo a lot of it okay other
things that other things that I like so
president Trump again I say that he has
the power to the ability to use troller
e for the power of good and he does have
the ability to use troller e for the
power of good this is one of those
situations so as an Orthodox Jew I
really like that the United States is a
Christian nation because I think the
closer that the United States is to its
Christian roots the closer they are to
their biblical roots and the closer they
are to their biblical roots at least in
private values the better off the
country is in terms of social structure
president Trump was obviously out there
signaling that he made a big part of his
campaign that merry Christmas will come
back again now I always thought this was
a little overblown everybody was able to
say Merry Christmas to each other it was
never illegal but the President of the
United States saying it obviously is
attempting to make a culture statement a
lot of people on the left are maddened
by this but I don't think that most of
the people in the center either care or
or oppose it so here as president Trump
overtly invoking Jesus during Christmas
which seems to me to make sense since I
don't celebrate Christmas because it's
about the Jesus so here is here's Donald
Trump finally in 1870 president eliches
Grant signed legislation making
Christmas a federal holiday and I sort
of feel we're doing that again that's
what's happening from the earliest days
of our nation Americans have known
christmas is a time for prayer and
worship for gratitude and goodwill for
peace and renewal Melania and I are full
of joy at the start of this very blessed
season we're thrilled to think of the
people across the nation and all across
the continents whose spirits are lifted
by the miracle of Christmas for
Christians this is a holy season the
celebration of the birth of our Lord and
Savior Jesus okay so I'll be honest with
you I don't think that Trump knows
anything about Christmas like I don't
think he's a deeply religious guy he's
never really given the indication that
he is but am I glad that the President
of the United States is even paying lip
service to the Christian nature of the
country and the Christian nature of the
of Christmas itself yes I'm very glad
that he's doing it so good for president
Trump
for doing that he's gotten a lot of
flack for it I think that flack is
stupid so good for President Trump on
that okay things that I hate so first of
all the first thing that I hate is that
I have to make corrections so I have a
couple of Corrections this week so
number one like an idiot I suggested
that the president didn't know much
about the Windtalkers because he doesn't
but then it turned out that I don't know
much worth Windtalkers either so I have
to apologize for getting that wrong I
suggest that the Navajo Windtalkers had
decoded German and Japanese messages
that of course is untrue the Navajo
Windtalkers instead had they spoke
Navajo and so they were used as as
basically message purveyors by the
American government and their language
is so different from any other language
on planet earth apparently that the
Japanese thought it was artificial they
didn't know how to decode it and so they
could convey messages that way so that
is a correction I got a lot of emails on
that thank you forever by the way folks
when you see that I do something wrong
on the shadow me know like politically
wrongs I'm never politically wrong but
when I am but when I'm factually
incorrect please let me know because I'm
more than happy to make the correction
because I don't want to give that
information other information I said
that Teresa may was a member of the
brexit party what I meant by that was
not that the Conservative Party in
Britain supported breakfast they didn't
David Cameron didn't but Theresa May was
as I understand it and correct me if I'm
wrong Theresa May was not opposed to
brexit which is one of the reasons why
she took the place of David Cameron when
David Cameron stepped down okay
let's just go directly to the mail bag
because that's an I really hate
Corrections and I had to do them so
we're just going to mail back now okay
so Eric yes hey Ben I love your show I'm
a Mormon from a Mormon family strangely
enough I had to eat Thanksgiving dinner
on the porch after arguing extensively
about abortion how can I help my family
close an extended see the inconsistency
of being pro-abortion and having a firm
faith in God thank you well you know I
think that you know I tend not to make
the argument about abortion on the basis
of God I tend to make it on the basis of
science because I think that's more
convincing if you believe in the
sanctity of human life and I assume that
they do then you have to ask all the
same questions that I often ask about
abortion what constitutes human life is
human life breathing because there are
plenty people who aren't on an iron lung
can you just unplug it is human life
brain activity because when you are
sleeping or when you are in a coma your
brain activity is minimal is in and when
you're a fetus then you are developing
brain activity so you are going to come
out of that there will be brain activity
even if you believe that that the the
initial cells don't have brain activity
which they don't is is your standard
something else as to what constitutes
humanity well you're going to have to
explain why we can't kill adults the
bottom line is that once the once
insemination has taken place once the
once the egg has been fertilized once
fertilization has taken place then you
have an incipient human life even if you
don't wish to say that it has the same
moral status as a full human being it
certainly has enough moral status that
you don't get to kill it it will because
that is a at the very least a potential
human life and and therefore you know
that is not worth killing I think that
it's it's difficult to make the case
it's not human life frankly the grainery
says dear Ben I hear the argument for me
the private businesses should have the
right not to not serve whomever they
please that the free market would
discourage the use of this policy to
discriminate because people don't like
racism and such I agree so this position
still hold in the time period directly
after the abolition of slavery when
there is very little free market
provision from discrimination if yes
does this not prolong segregation so the
answer is that the free markets of the
north were significantly better at
restricting the discrimination than the
very restrictive markets of the south
Jim Crow laws came in and ensured they
were specifically designed to prevent
free market development of
anti-discrimination so I'm not saying
that everybody is grand and everybody is
great I am saying that everybody does
like money and if they see money to be
made then they're going to appeal to
populations that were otherwise
marginalized
so that doesn't mean that in every
situation there won't be private
discrimination I don't believe that you
know in the aftermath of slavery of
course there was gonna be lots of
private discrimination but the federal
government because of that the federal
government wasn't even willing to put
anti-discrimination law and policy in
the first place at that point so the
best you could do is free markets
usually it's the government used the
other way usually it's the government
preventing anti-discrimination by
actually forcing discrimination geniuses
and pretty involved in charity and
outreach many are surprised to learn my
political and conservative views how can
conservatives combat this and be seen
more as a champion for the people well
number one I think that we have to
actually do something that we all we all
as religious people find kind of
unpalatable and not really nice
Maimonides when he talks about charity
says that charity the highest form of
charity is giving anonymously and I but
well he says the highest one was giving
somebody a job the second highest form
is giving anonymously I think that is
right because you don't want to glorify
yourself for doing something that you
are obligated to do right give charity
religiously but if conservatives don't
make clear to people they're actually
doing that and
people don't identify them as charitable
so we're actually gonna have to brag on
ourselves a little bit we're actually
gonna have to say that we do give
charity we give lots more charity than
people on the Left do this is a fact red
states give lots more charity than blue
states per capita red the religious
people give lots more charity than
non-religious people so if you want to
talk about how much we care about people
why don't you look to the people who are
volunteering signing checks as opposed
to doing it at the point of a gun Morgan
says Ben is your children grow do you
plan on limiting their use of technology
like tablets iPads etc yes they already
I mean until she was 2 my daughter
didn't watch television
my son doesn't watch TV I limit her use
of TV pretty significantly in terms of
what she is allowed to watch and I plan
on doing the same with computers I would
want her to use computers in order to
gather information but smartphones iPads
these have become distraction tools as
opposed to learning tools and so I think
that I would much rather she read a book
than be caught up in the social media on
the internet like for example I wouldn't
want my daughter to have a Facebook
account until she was in her teens like
I just don't think children should have
that stuff or her Twitter account Scott
says what is your stance on net
neutrality given how the Internet has
become such an important part of how we
learn so I don't believe in net
neutrality I think I'd explained this a
few days ago on the show tonight I did a
whole segment on net neutrality I
thought where I discussed at length the
idea that the ISPs basically net
neutrality is the suggestion there's
only put into place in the last couple
of years of the Obama administration and
before that the internet was working
just fine net neutrality is basically
the suggestion that internet service
providers have to supply traffic supply
all use of traffic the same price so
Netflix which eats up an enormous amount
of bandwidth has to be charged the same
as some shmo and his basement who is
just loading up his blog and it's also
net neutrality also says that all pages
have to be loaded at the same speed well
the problem with that of course is that
it benefits big corporations like
Netflix over the little guy the the
reality is that if you're taking up a
huge share of the bandwidth then you
might there might be companies that say
you know we will provide you a faster
access but you have to pay more money
it's not incumbent on Internet service
providers to be forced to be treated
like public utilities the way to think
of it is that Internet service providers
are like the pipes and the int and the
content of the Internet is like water so
you can think of it in two ways it's a
public utility everybody should be able
to turn on the tap
same time and get the water or that the
pipe company should be able to charge
you what they want or charge the the
water company what it wants for the
water moving through the pipes the
reason it's not quite like a pipe is
because you can have multiple pipes
right there multiple internet service
providers one of the reasons that net
neutrality has become such an issue is
because of special deals with local
governments by a lot of the Internet
service providers so the only providers
in their region if they were open
competition you would actually see
competition like for people for example
who only use email but don't watch
streaming video right like older people
who only want to watch TV but don't
actually want to use Netflix or Hulu
they should be able to get the internet
cheaper then people who want to be able
to get Netflix and Hulu right or if you
only wanna get Netflix and Hulu and you
don't use email right just these text
messages you should be able to have
these options there's nothing wrong with
any of this
the this is why when people say it's a
corporate giveaway and to get rid of net
neutrality there major corporations like
Google and Netflix who basically want to
prevent smaller companies from being
able to take advantage of differential
pricing on ISPs to compete with them so
it depends which corporations you're
talking about Google is a huge
corporation Facebook's a huge
corporation twitter is a huge
corporation all of them are in favor of
net neutrality because they are content
providers all the ISPs are in favor of
getting rid of net neutrality bottom
line is the internet was fine before
anybody started messing with it net
neutrality the the odd passion over net
neutrality has always puzzled me motion
says hi Ben everyone appreciate when the
North Korean soldier fled the regime and
made his escape to freedom logistically
what is the difference between that
soldier and Mexican citizens wanting to
escape to a better life in America love
the show so I don't as I've said before
I think people who are trying to escape
horrible situations to come to a better
life
I don't blame somebody for trying to
jump the border I've said this many
times and I've been very clear about
this and pretty consistent on it if I
were living in Mexico I'd also try to
jump the border because America's an
amazing place if I had no other choice
but that does not mean that the United
States has an obligation to take those
people in it doesn't the US gets to pick
who gets to come into the country and
who does not the u.s. gets to do that so
it's not up to South Korea to say we're
going we must take in everyone from
North Korea
right the South Korea can say no we're
gonna put that person in in some sort of
temporary internment camp until we can
figure out where they ought to immigrate
to for example but the idea that
everyone who is fleeing human rights
violations has a has a therefore a
a claim on your country is not true also
I would say the de Mexico government is
not equivalent to the North Korean
government anyway
there are lots of problems in Mexico
including drug cartels but Mexico is not
North Korea and North Korea is a giant
prison state there is no wall keeping
Mexicans in okay um Damian says I was
talking about God with my friend he said
since God is Almighty why would he tests
us by giving us free will and god is
almighty so he knows the future I would
know the results of that free will test
what can I answer God wants us to earn
God wants us to feel fulfilled one of
the way God loves us and so he wants us
to feel fulfilled the way that people
feel fulfilled is not by being given
things and it's not even if you know the
what somebody's gonna do it's being
given a choice and then acting in
accordance with that free will freewill
is what makes life meaningful so I what
I would ask your friend is how he would
define the the existence of free will
without God or without a supernatural if
you're a scientific materialist there is
no evidence whatsoever that free will
exist
Shawn says have you thought about your
new year's resolution yeah well actually
the truth is that Jews do our New Year's
resolutions around Rosh Hashanah during
the Jewish New Year that's why we do it
in actual atonement I would say the
Jewish New Year is a lot more meaningful
than the secular new year where we all
get drunk and then pretend we're gonna
lose weight and then don't tom says last
week you said DC movies should have 20%
added to their critical scores Marvel
movies should have 20% taken away why do
you think DC movie should receive
affirmative action shouldn't have to
stand on their own mediocrity I'm not
saying that Rotten Tomatoes has to do
that I'm saying if you want an accurate
portrayal of how DC movies are treated
then you should add like in your own
mind you should add 20% to the Rotten
Tomatoes score because everything they
say is 34 DC movies of 50 and everything
they say is in 90 from Marvel movies of
70 that's all I'm saying I'm saying the
bottom the critics are biased in favor
of Marvel and they are biased against DC
but I'm not saying that that the critics
have to do that I mean the critics can
do it over the hell they want that's why
I don't pay attention to the critics a
lot how Luke says heaven I've heard you
say you do not believe Jesus was the son
of God my question is have you read CS
is CS Lewis's true lemma where he
concedes as a Christian that if Jesus
was not God then he was a madman or
something worse even you don't think
Jesus was divine weren't his words or
actions wickedly immoral thanks an
Aussie atheist conservative fan no so
one of the reasons that Jews reject
Jesus is because we don't believe the
authenticity of the Gospels meaning that
if we actually believed the offense and
so CS is CS Lewis's proof relies on you
believing the historicity of the Gospels
everything the gospel said was true and
therefore either Jesus was crazy or
Jesus was evil or G's was telling the
truth
right that's the trilemma well I don't
think that like as a Jew like the Jewish
perspective on Jesus is that that's not
actually the case right the Jewish
perspective on geez is that the people
who wrote the Gospels were writing the
Gospels decades after Jesus's death and
that Jesus was actually pretty much a
normal Orthodox Jew who tried to lead a
rebellion against the Romans as was
killed for his trouble that's that he
was attempting to lead a secular
messianic movement because that's in
when I say secular I mean a Jewish
messianic movement that is the Jewish
Messiah has no there's no notion of
divinity entering the world through the
Jewish Messiah tom says is Michael knows
on salary or paid per word sadly Michael
Knowles is on salary I have desperately
been trying to pay him forward for a
couple of years now again one of the
great moments of my career will be
firing Michael moles Jonathan says Ben
what role if any should opinion post
play in the decision-making process for
politicians well they should be used as
feedback but they shouldn't be used as
guidance so what I mean by that is it's
good to know what people like and what
people don't because that also allows
you to tailor your message on what is
good policy but I don't think that that
you should shift your policy preferences
based on public opinion I don't think
that it should be like well I'm for tax
cuts but now that the public hates a
time for tax increases I don't think
that's right you should either believe
that something's gonna work or believe
that it's not gonna work and facts are
facts and feelings are feelings Elena
says hey Ben if you had to pick a single
moment or a period of time that
profoundly impacted your life what would
it be um well I honestly believe I
haven't been alive very long monly 33 so
I believe that there have been several
you know kind of key periods of my life
I would say that one of one of those key
periods was when I was growing up and I
went to middle school I went to public
school and I was viciously bullied there
and then I was viciously bullied in high
school I think that's a it's not a good
thing that it happened but it's a
character building exercise you have to
grow a thick skin and you have to learn
that that the world is not your friend
and they're gonna have to make your own
way and so I think that was a deeply
upsetting but but valuable experience to
me Harvard Law School is a great place
to learn how to argue and learn how to
think I think that the last year and a
half has been a really tremendous
character-building experience and a know
and has changed my my thought process
he's really interesting the other day
and some of you wrote a column
criticizing me and talking about a
column I wrote in 2007 about the about
dissenters from the Iraq war they're a
bunch of Democrats at the time like to
and who are talking about how they were
glad that America was basically losing
the war in Iraq and I said this was
traitorous essentially and in a column I
even said that we should rien it we
should revivify the alien sedition and
they did not the alien Sedition Acts the
Espionage Act of 1917 under Woodrow
Wilson I feel and then Barack Obama
became president and you become the
dissent and then you realize well you're
going to have to have a certain standard
it's easy to be the people in power and
it's hard to be the people out of power
and then during this election cycle the
question was were you going to maintain
that standard now that you had the
possibility of power again and I think
the answer is that if you're not
learning throughout your life and
changing how you feel based on new
evidence not based on new feelings but
based on new evidence then you're not
doing the right job I wish I hadn't
written that 2007 column outs I don't
think that's right I don't think that
the Espionage Act should be revivified
against people even people who say
egregious things about war and and you
know say things that harm the war effort
and I think put the troops in a bad
position free speech is valuable because
you can end up on the wrong side of it
so there are certain areas in America in
in life where I've changed my position
because new evidence has been presented
to me that I had not experienced before
the Obama administration changed my way
of thought the Bush administration
changed my way of thought the Trump
administration changes my way of thought
if you're not changing your way of
thought based on new evidence then
you've stopped thinking and you've
become rigid and sort of locked in
Daniel says what is your favorite Star
Wars film so clearly Empire is the best
I mean there's the that's the easiest
answer ever the question is what comes
second right because there there are
there are a couple of like the only the
hard choice there as to what comes
second is actually in my opinion between
Episode four and rogue one I really do
like rogue one rogue one is a very good
movie when I first watched it I was
really tired and I underestimated how
good it was that I watched it again on a
plane actually and it's a very very good
movie so I would still probably put
rogue one third I'd probably still go
Empire Star Wars one rogue one Return of
the Jedi we were just discussing before
the show actually how good is Return of
the Jedi and the problem with Return of
the Jedi is that it's actually two
movies right so there's the this all the
stuff with Luke aboard the Death Star
which is some of the best stuff in the
Star Wars series and then there's all
the stuff with the Ewoks and you're like
what why who when where well who
and it doesn't make any sense so the so
all the stuff aboard the Death Star is
fantastic if that had been the entirety
of Return of the Jedi then Return of the
Jedi would be up there it comes in
fourth for me so those are my top four
Brendan says hey Ben I've recently been
growing interesting increasingly
interested in listening to some
classical music are there any pieces of
work that you'd recommend to someone
that is just starting out well they're
there there's so many pieces that are
great for people who are just starting
out with classical music a lot of them
are cliched so you want to actually
listen to some stuff that I'd have to
know sort of what music you like believe
it or not in sort of the Papa Rina to
know what music you would like in
classical but you would have to start
anybody would have to start with some
Bach start with Toccata and Fugue which
is very user friendly when I was younger
I really like to force rock to New World
Symphony which is really exciting and
fun to listen to the Mozart's the the
overture for Don Giovanni and the lasted
the last number for Don Giovanni number
the last the last Aria and Don Giovanni
our second to last Aria and Don Giovanni
where Don Giovanni is dragged to hell
spoiler alert that that is a that is a
fantastic fantastic piece of classical
music
Brahms the second piano concerto is just
great Edvard Grieg is really
user-friendly and you'll recognize a lot
of Grigg like Greg is in the hall of the
Mountain King you'll recognize it if
you're old enough from the Ritz crackers
commercials the cheese commercials right
I said that's Greek so is the music that
you always hear the dog that's also
Greek so a lot of very colorful
classical music busy Carmen there's so
much great classical music I start with
the colorful stuff and then make it word
make your way toward the harder stuff
mistake people make is they don't know
anything so they say I'll start off with
Beethoven's first symphony it's not even
the good stuff Beethoven's best
Beethoven's good stuff starts Beethoven
three right the Eroica okay Bryce says
hey Ben I love everything you do I'm a
huge supporter of capitalism but I also
don't seem to be very good at it fair
I'm still following the three rules but
I'm about to graduate college it's clear
I have bad skills when it comes to
handling my money do you have any advice
on how I could be better with money and
are there any resources you could point
me toward in the advancement of my
wealth management skills I mean first of
all I would find an actual wealth
manager or somebody who can help you
allocate your budget so number one I
think Dave Ramsey does some good work on
this if you're really bad with handling
money you should not have a credit card
you should only have a debit card
you should only be able to take money
out of your account that already exists
so all of your costs should be cash in
hand cash out of pocket that seems to me
a very good way of preventing yourself
from running into serious debt which is
where people really get into trouble
also what I say is that recognize the
stuff that's gonna bankrupt you and the
stuff that's not gonna bankrupt you it's
not gonna bankrupt you to go to a movie
once a week it will bankrupt you get an
expensive car so there's sort of these
big purchases that people spend a lot of
money on that are worthless
you're better off living a quote-unquote
rich lifestyle by going to a movie once
a week which makes you feel rich and
makes you feel involved in the world as
opposed to getting a nice car which
honestly is separated from like a
mediocre car by 0.1% of enjoyment for
most people for some people who really
love cars I guess it's a big deal but
for me it never was like I had a Mustang
I had a GT Mustang that I paid like
$33,000 for when I got out of law school
and I was making a lot of money at a law
firm and and I didn't really enjoy that
car that much to be frank with you I
mean my wife didn't enjoy it so when we
actually replaced it with the Honda
Pilot which is a family car I like the
Honda Pilot better than I enjoyed my GT
Mustang especially because you got a car
with a really nice engine and you really
want to speed in it and there's no place
in California to speed in that car right
you're gonna get arrested immediately
plus because you're gonna get a ticket
every two seconds because the cops are
looking for those cars Kevin says some
time ago a close family friend switched
from being an obstetrician working at a
hospital to being an obstetrician
working for Planned Parenthood he and
his family were always pro-choice but
now he is an active participant in
legalized murder can our relationship
even continue I can't think of anything
to say they could reach someone who's
conscience is that seared should I ask
him what it would take to get him to
quit I mean if you're that close friends
with him you might say to him listen I'm
having real moral qualms about about
honestly like having a relationship with
somebody who in my opinion kills babies
for a living like I want to have this
conversation you don't want to be
friends with you but I understand if we
can't continue that relationship I
totally got that I totally got that I
mean if somebody is committing what you
believe to be a moral atrocity on a
regular basis it's very difficult I was
talking with friend about this last
night and one of the things that I think
is actually bad and wrong is that we in
our personal lives will take people who
we know our garbage people and will say
oh he's a nice guy he's a nice guy
and then he gets away and then he does
some bad things because we said oh he's
a nice guy garbage people people who do
garbage things I'm not sure she'd be
treated with kid gloves Tim says finally
why do ex-husbands still have to take
care of ex-wives in a divorce I
understand the reasoning behind
back before women had rights and were
able to work but today they have rights
and want even more and they should and
they are more than capable of finding
jobs to support themselves without a man
so again why do we still have a judicial
system that favors women now why would I
lose my house that I pay for and she
gets half of my assets on top of it if I
didn't break the marriage agreement this
seems to me a perfectly fair question on
the back of feminists if it seems to me
child support is entirely appropriate
but in a in a world in which men and
women are equally capable of holding
jobs in the world in which women who are
single straight out of college not
married no kids are actually making more
than men in most of America's major
cities I think that it may be a time to
look back at how we arrange these things
there are situations by the way in which
women are paying support to men they're
paying spousal support amend but that's
rare there there is a bias in our
judicial system against men with regard
to parenting as well as as well as
marital law okay so this brings us to
the end of today's program just news
breaking fast and furious this week this
was a long week we'll be back here on
Monday and by that point I can only
expect that the aliens will have arrived
given the the quick-moving news cycle in
which we are now taking part but try not
to run things while I'm gone I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jael para the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford Publishing